[Music]
[Music]
for example here we go in Tampa Florida
any meth lab within 30 feet of a school
must have a ball pit that's a law you've
got to know that in Racine Wisconsin
it's legal to bite a child if you
suspect he has cheese in his pocket in
Los Angeles California it is legal to
own a self-driving car but only if it
still parts like an [ __ ] in Portland
Oregon guys without beards can be
arrested for indecent exposure in Las
Vegas Nevada a woman may not breastfeed
in public without a tip jar in Alabama
if the gun store doesn't have a
drive-thru window you're allowed to make
one wait a minute something went really
wrong there which what did you just read
Alabama
okay Alabama what's that a wrong Alabama
100k well that can happen
we okay oh we just got a thumbs up from
someone who I don't even think works at
the show let's can't let's continue
alright in West Virginia it's illegal
for your people to own a Coonhound that
ain't named woods in Duluth Minnesota
you can be arrested for possession of
salad with intent to distribute in New
Jersey it's illegal to leave a
Springsteen concert before the fourth
encore do it alright do it in Alabama if
the gun store doesn't have a drive-thru
window you're allowed to make
all right people cut together fine in
Oklahoma it's illegal to have a Hillary
sticker on your car unless Calvin is
peeing on it in Sarasota Florida it's a
misdemeanor to walk away from an elderly
person who's telling you what life was
like when coke was a nickel and finally
in Arizona it's illegal to refer to the
Grand Canyon as Earth's lady parts
[Applause]
you